here's Johnny why so serious I'll be
back I believe in you evil geniuses
cold-blooded killing machines
sadistic psychos movie villains have
taken on a variety of name shapes and
sizes one thing they all have in common
they keep us on the edge of our seats
I'm going to count to three
actually Hans we're counting down the
top 12 because everybody loves to hate a
good villain and number 12
the t1000 he was an overwhelming upgrade
from the original Terminator and a whole
lot harder to stop you could shoot him
freeze him cut him in half but that
would only slow him down plus he could
impersonate your closest friends and
family if an emotionless liquid metal
killing machine doesn't scare you
I don't know what will number 11 Hans
Gruber from die hard the well-dressed
German Terrace was the perfect adversary
for Bruce Willis he was conniving and
calculated organizing a near perfect
takeover of a Los Angeles high-rise an
attempt to steal hundreds of millions of
dollars
unfortunately he underestimated the
courage of John McClane and that was his
literal downfall
at number 10 Patrick Bateman from
American Psycho part-time Wall Street
yuppie and part-time serial killer he's
unreasonably obsessed with his
appearance health money and even music
collection he has a penchant for axes
nail guns and chainsaws no one is safe
in this story including the homeless
prostitutes and rival investment bankers
and number nine
Colonel Hans Landa inglourious basterds
Londe used every resource he could to
pursue all Jews and hiding and occupied
France he was exceptionally intelligent
and precise as a detective but
ultimately proved to care more about
self-preservation than the Nazi agenda
Londe ends up selling out Hitler and a
theater full of his followers for
immunity and a life in the United States
if you wanted to win the war tonight I
have to make a deal number 8 Michael
Myers Halloween a legendary serial
killer that's been around for decades
Michael Myers is evil that cannot be
stopped as a six year old he murdered
his older sister on Halloween night and
was kept in a sanitarium until he
escaped years later for the next 40
years he would seek vengeance against
the nice people of Haddonfield Illinois
good luck with that one guys at 7 Freddy
Krueger he's been haunting our dreams
since the 1984 classic A Nightmare on
Elm Street Krueger tortured and murdered
the children of Springwood Ohio when
they're at their most vulnerable while
dreaming nightmares of that signature
Claude gloves still haunt me to this day
number 6 John Doe from 7 Kevin Spacey
plays this psychopathic serial killer
perfectly Doe is infatuated with the
seven deadly sins of Christianity and
disposes of his victims with symbolic
murders he's a twisted mastermind
playing a horrific game with the
authorities chasing him doe is evil
personified and leaves you feeling sick
up into the final moments of the
movements become vengeance
raph told me she's alright at five Anton
Chigurh no country for old men here's
proof a really bad haircut can make you
an even better bad guy Javier Bardem s
character was utterly unstoppable
efficient and mysterious his lack of
conscience and fascination with coin
flips and cattle guns makes him one of
the most menacing villains in movie
history and number four the Joker I know
I know this is cheating I'm highlighting
one character but two actors with this
one the Joker was played perfectly by
both Jack Nicholson and Heath Ledger one
brought the cartoon and comedic version
and the other a dark and brooding
performance worthy of an Academy Award
the upcoming Suicide Squad will feature
yet another actor as the Clown Prince of
Crime Jared Leto who has some awfully
big shoes to fill I'm just gonna hurt
you really really third on the list is
Darth Vader this one might surprise you
some believe Darth Vader should probably
top this list but he wasn't always a big
bad villain before turning over the
darkside Anakin Skywalker was a highly
skilled Jedi in training who lost all of
his loved ones filled with rage the Sith
Lord and his iconic red lightsaber set
out to eradicate the Jedi Order the
runner-up on this list Hannibal Lecter
an extremely intelligent but mentally
ill serial killer
he took enjoyment in eating the flesh of
others everyone on this list is
disgusting but seriously being a former
psychiatrist Hannibal took pleasure in
playing games with the authorities
especially when Clarice Starling I ate
his liver with some fava beans and a
nice
and the top spot goes to none other than
Emperor Palpatine the reason he's the
ultimate behind-the-scenes bad guy
the Emperor is also responsible for
Darth Vader's rank on this list so
double points for you Palpatine he
manipulated those with less power and it
was responsible for probably billions of
lives he's the ultimate mastermind
behind everything evil going on in the
Star Wars saga so what do you think of
our favorite villains and movies did we
miss one of your all-time favorites are
there any movie villains you're looking
forward to watching hit us up in the
comments section and let us know and
stay tuned for more lists right here on
gamespot